elle s'est arrêtée au cmp et a demandé à
me voir
l'infirmier à l'accueil n'a pas pu lui
et non c'est la règle de la consultation
uniquement sur rendez vous dans la salle
d'attenté alors que je me dirigeais vers
un client
cette jeune femme m'a lancé un regard
d'une telle détresse que je n'ai plus
honorablement refusé sa demande il me
semble est vital de la recevoir
elle était venue avec deux enfants 10 en
huit ans ce matin-là elle les avait
embarqué dans sa voiture avec une seule
idée en tête les précipiter avec elle du
haut de la falaise
nous avons convenu d'un suivi
psychothérapeutique
aujourd'hui les enfants grandis la mer
va bien
cette rencontre a suscité une
interrogation à propos des dispositifs
codifié offert à la libération de la
parole à la lourdeur de la machine
administrative au moc de réactivité face
à une situation d'immédiateté vous pas
plus que d'autres
vous n'êtes à l'abri de tout rebond
soudain qui ferait vaciller le socle de
vote construction psychique semblable à
cet homme qui apprend qu'il est atteint
du virus du sida
la nouvelle le terrasse et là une
famille comment rentrer à la maison
quoi dit
à quels amis pourraient avoir en partage
cette chose si difficile à porter la
multiplicité des outils informatiques
n'a pas augmenté la capacité d'une
communication adaptée au contraire le
chausson et récits communiqué c'est
d'abord écouté l'expérience est caduque
quand celui qui a été choisi comme
confident et pan ils le donnent vraiment
entendre son histoire personnelle déjà
surinam endolori
comment parler à quelqu'un yeux rivés
sur son téléphone portable qui n'a plus
de thon pour rien pressé de regagner son
monde virtuel qui n'évalue absolument
pas la gravité du dire dans la
communication parallèle
j'en donne ici un exemple deux personnes
ce pâle l'une dit mon enfant est en
garde à vue l'autre de répondre je vais
courir les soldes à moins 70% de
réduction tu viens je suis anéantie je
ne sais que faire
hier j'ai acheté un petit boléro pour
une bouchée de pain
je te le montrerai
ces attitudes des notes des formes du
rhin fut d'intercepter la douleur
d'autrui
comme si par phénomène mimétique elle
sera prêt un satisfaction et frustration
le futur ne cicatrise la p11 du mal
aujourd'hui dire se confier à quelqu'un
si on courir le risque nutty fusion de
l'information on donne en pâture à des
milliers de gens sur des réseaux sociaux
des condoléances
entre autres qui devrait être quelque
chose de l'ordre de l'intimé
la prudence est de mise le désarroi n'a
pas obligatoirement besoin d'une
consultation psy ils n'aspirent qu'à
être compris et entendus pas de
n'importe quelle façon pas de l'est pas
n'importe comment libérer la parole
quand l'insupportable submerge
l objectif premier de l'asu lingerie
j'étais content cette concept tout à
fait novateur qui sera ouvert à tout
public à partir de 16 ans
pourquoi saison cet âge autorise un
enfant à recevoir les mêmes soins
connaît du ltte à ne plus être
hospitalisé dans un service de pédiatrie
à faire quelques démarches sans être
accompagnés d'un parent il suffira un
jour de permanence sans rendez vous
préalable de pousser la porte
poussez la porte n'est pas aussi simple
qu'il y paraît et pourtant les anglo
saxons affirme que le bonheur et behind
the doors le bonheur est derrière la
porte
la décision prise un thérapeute en
psychologue psychothérapeute au
psychanalyste psychiatre va pouvoir
écouter tout un chacun mais j'insiste
beaucoup sur cette notion de
professionnalisme
parce que cet exercice n'est ni simple
il faut énormément de doigté et
d'expériences nul préoccupations
financières ne devrait hanter cette
paire sad qui vient dire l'indicible la
gratuité de la prestation des ce cri
dans une espèce de chaîne de solidarité
une aide apportée au mal être de
l'humanité
la séance est unique en si on doit se
voir une seconde fois ils nous
rappellent troisième parce que la
soulage riz n'a pas vocation de prendre
en charge à moyen terme ou à long terme
elle n'est pas une urgence psy ou une
équipe traiterait en première instance
des troubles du comportement
elle n'est pas non plus un centre de
cris qui auraient en train vers d'autres
structures des personnes n'ayant pas le
profil correspondant à la philosophie du
système
la sauvagerie a comme principe à des
principes
elle repose sur un face à face avec un
thérapeute de la présence est
indispensable parce que la parole est au
centre de la rencontre
et si d'aventuré quelqu'un comme souvent
ça arrive en psychanalyse son mur dans
un mutisme profond on n'obtiendra pas
les insultait comptait déposer un
fardeau se soulager son tendre mettre
des mots sur une situation douloureuse
sans contour et c'est déjà une avancée
vers l'apaisement tout ceci n'a rien à
voir avec certaines thérapies brèves où
on arrive avec un problème et où on
repart avec seul un problème augmenté
d'une énigme quand le doute à rod sur
les compétences sont quand le coeur en
écharpe réactive des blessures
narcissiques
quand la pulsions destructrices conduit
au bord du passage à l'acte
oui la slaj riz répond à un besoin
justement de juguler cette violence qui
est de moins en moins contenue
tout le monde dans l'anonymat pas de
dossier pas de discrimination de
couverture sociale pourra en bénéficier
en individuel ou en groupe
le séisme de 2010 qui a ravagé haïti a
permis de tester son efficacité
les parents puis les enfants ont été
entendus
le stress post traumatique ayant donné
lieu nous selon ce stress pour les
adultes mais pour les enfants ce stress
post traumatique de la catastrophe
perçue non vécu mes peines ayant donné
lieu à l'éclosion de symptômes la
démarche ne s'est pas seulement tenu au
débriefing émotionnel mais l'originalité
a été de se faire se rencontrer des
personnes d'un même pays pouvant
effectivement évoqué un ressenti
similaire dans une espèce de bulle de
sentiment d'appartenance l'exil est
temps parfois un élément des
organisateurs de l'identité et si par
mégarde croyons s'adresser un
psychanalyste pour chiens et chats parce
que la bête ne miaule nina bois quelques
pousse la porte
le psychanalyste devra assumer et est
cité la parole est respectives sur le
propriétaire de l'animal
la réception du public doit se faire
dans un lieu dénué de connotations de
soins parce que l'objectif n'est pas de
soigner mais d'autoriser à tout dire
sans restriction sans crête des juges et
d'évoquer des tracasseries qui se
meuvent en irritabilité choisir cette
voie de dégagement pour déposer vraiment
se délester de poids la municipalité me
semble le lieu le mieux approprié à la
plantation de cette sauvagerie parce que
elle revint de caractère de neutralité
chacun peut s'y rendre
qui en toute quiétude de ja qui pour un
document officiel qui pour une
publication du nom de mariage la mairie
devrait tête la maison du peuple
la sauvagerie peut être reproduite à
l'identique dans les villes
cette mairie cette municipalité voudrait
revenir sur elle la municipalité parce
qu on pourrait valider la joue lingerie
dans ce lieu les plus représentatifs la
soulage riz peut être reproduit à
l'infini dans les villes selon il
faudrait que des bénévoles thérapeute
s'y engage
et si d'aventuré il n'y a personne
je pense qu'on peut être formé le
carrefour de solidarité des solidarités
au nom évocateur le carrefour des
solidarités se trouve dans 20 villes aux
noms évocateurs reçoit quand il le faut
de façon sporadique
pour le moment la détresse de tous le
premier édile se donne les moyens de
participer au bien être de ses
concitoyens sans parti pris
en mettant à disposition les équipements
quand les 110 d'un immeuble à porter
atteinte aux gens et aux biens
la parole entendue a mis un jour une
culpabilité des voisins s'accusent ont
des différences et de nos solidarités
à partir de là les nuits blanches de
l'ong one se sont estompées basée sur le
bénévolat
un soulagement n'est pas dénué des tic
ce projet doit être soumis au conseil
municipal mais il ne doit pas exercer un
contrôle
il offre juste l'espace de réception
les intervenants devront acquis c'est un
certain nombre de critères basés sur des
valeurs inaliénables l'indispensable
professionnalisme l'engagement bénévole
le respect des jours de permanence
l'adhésion au principe de la séance
unique ans et l'acceptation du principe
ne pas nuire
la diffusion du projet auprès d'un
organisme regroupant des travailleurs de
la santé mentale du spécialiste surtout
la publicité médiatique devrait susciter
pas mal d'intérêt dans un ton ce goût la
publication de projets de recherche
portant sur ce qui a été exprimé afin de
mieux cerner les difficultés d'une
population dont le vent de la modernité
devra être traités chaque jour la
démonstration marketing et prennent les
imaginaires à des fins de consommation
peu d espace est réservé
au besoin de dire à des fins d'une
décharge de trot plat et pourtant qui
n'a pas quelque chose a confié à
quelqu'un dans cette salle